and so to help a patient see progress
you have to ask
questions about things just outside of
pain score
and you have to make them both specific
enough and general enough
that the patient can see progress
throughout
[Music]
rachel tropman thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders welcome
hi thank you so much for having me
michael
of course where in the world are you
right now i
am in new jersey south orange new jersey
which is
uh not too far from the city of new york
that's an interesting name south orange
i like that
yes it feels like uh
exactly but uh that's exactly what it
feels like
but uh what i really want to start
talking about is your fun fact
you're in peru how do you get to sew
somebody's arm back uh with without even
being a doctor but
even if you were a doctor it sounds
crazy what happened over there
ah so when i was in college
i spent the summer living in urbamba
peru which is like a
small town in the sacred valley i was
working for an ngo
and they put me because i was interested
in medicine and science
and a working in a hospital
i didn't speak any spanish at the time i
spoke fluent french
and the doctor that i was working with
didn't speak any english
so i would ask him questions in french
and he would respond in spanish and
that's how
we got by um and mostly mostly what i
was doing was like doing patient intake
um taking notes um
kind of like setting and doing triage
for the doctor
but one day he was i forget what he was
doing he was
like catering to another patient and
this patient came in having accidentally
chopped his arm off on his birthday
and they needed somebody to like start
doing the sutures right away and the
doctor was like
you could get started and i was like
what do you mean i could get started
and he's like just there's all of all
the tools that you need are in
the room and so i was like i'm terrified
just listening to this i was like okay
i guess we're doing this and they needed
hands and then of course he joined me
and
we like finished up the job but um
there's nothing quite like a threat of
just
you know losing hanukkah toys
um and so i yeah so
that's that's what happened that's how i
did it and
um thankfully i didn't have to do it the
most important question
yes is the man okay is the person okay
perv he's totally fine yep i went on to
do other x-rays i did not
go on to become a doctor um
realized that like emergency room trauma
was like
not my thing but it was yeah it was one
of those things where like i guess you
learn on the ground but it's not
anywhere else that would not be
acceptable but
there a guy lived totally fine and that
that's that story
i i i love that uh i can definitely i i
definitely feel my heart pumping and
terrified as you're telling that story
and just imagining myself in that
situation and i i don't know if i could
have done what you did
and so that's very impressive but rachel
even more impressive is is the
really unique and an amazing journey
that you've had you know both
both in the medical side but also in in
journalism and production and media
which is where i believe you spent quite
quite a long time in and partially
being a contributing author to in the
new york times
of all places which is incredible and
now most recently transitioned and
into the role of the ceo of upside
health without she as one of the
products
so rachel i have to understand a little
bit about your journey before we dive
into
the digital health markets talk to me
about how how do you go be
across these different industries yeah
well i mean for me
it really started from um
i was always interested in telling
people stories and in journalism in
media
um particularly in health journalism um
and i got my first job at new york one
uh
where i was on the digital side of
things
and in the early days of digital
journalism it was really just like
taking
stories that were made for production
for tv
and then editing them into something
that would work
somewhat digitally um and everyone
assumed that
digital journalists were coders at that
time anyone that was on the web
was considered a coder um but i was just
like it was the first
job i was able to get so i was a good
writer and was able to do it
um but being in that position offered me
a lot of opportunities to like
try my hand at shooting try my hand at
reporting try my hand at editing
um and it also gave me a chance to work
with content management systems
um and so i got pretty good at what i
was doing
and was poached to join a digital media
company as their first hire
and that was my first foray into the
startup world
and while there and i've always been
somebody who
as was attested by the hand
sewing experience if there was an
opportunity to learn something in real
time i'll take it
um i say yes before i say no um and so
here was an opportunity for me to emerge
my
like immerse myself in something that i
was very confident that i could execute
that i'd never done before and then i
quickly moved into like business
development and strategy
uh built the team from zero to like a
billion lifetime views in just
two years and um
this is kind of like on the side but i
my husband's a software engineer he's a
technologist
and in the early days of
iphone development and apps we decided
to try our hands at that
i would do the content he'd do the
development and so we got really good at
it
as well and it was a skill at that time
that not many people were doing
so people started hiring us to build
apps for them
and wow so so i left my
content development role and kind of
moved it into this new space
and started building for you know
fortune 500 companies startups
uh really leading product strategy
knowing that like being a good
storyteller
could transform based off the platform
and so if you know how to tell a good
story and make something compelling that
people
want to use or want to read or want to
experience
um you can transfer that skill
and and so when we got when we got
confident enough that we could build
something from ideation to execution
uh seamlessly i decided we were ready to
turn our attention to something more
personal which kind of brings us to
outside health you know when i was 17
i was diagnosed with the connective
tissue disease
that was incredibly painful
but i was at a unique albeit unfortunate
advantage in that my mom has lupus and
my brother has cystic fibrosis
so i grew up in environments where
managing complex chronic health
conditions
was the norm having a built-in
supportive environment
was always there um and yet even with
all of these things i found that
pain was a tripping point
right there there is no
seamless easy way to manage pain
because pain unlike some of the other
metrics that are being managed
are really subjective
and when a primary symptom of what
you're living with
is something that is really subjective
it becomes hard to communicate around
it feels hard to get validated um and
it's hard
to treat from just not just like
the patient perspective but also from
the clinician perspective
something that people don't know maybe
not think about with like a lot of
patients who have chronic diseases is
they spend a lot of time
with their doctors and if you're someone
like me
who you know has a journalistic
background who likes to ask questions
and hear
answers you get to know their pain
points really well
right uh and understand that like this
wasn't just something i was experiencing
as a patient saying like this is hard to
manage
and i'm frustrated and i'm isolated um
but also something that the clinicians
would say like
this isn't easy it's not easy for me
either
um and so i found that there was like an
opportunity right there
to help facilitate change
so how does that actually so first of
all give me a little bit of a broader
perspective into what's available today
and what what is
how many people are going through
somewhat of a similar experience or or
need help managing that experience
and which led to your understanding
there's actually not just
an opportunity to help some people but
but help a significant number of people
where it can actually be a viable
business that becomes upside health
great great question so yeah i mean it's
very i'm not running a non-profit here
as much as i would
you know love to be able to help people
just from that but like you have to
i was interested in building a business
because i saw
a a substantial problem as i said but
also a really large market opportunity i
mean there are 50 million americans
right some people will say 100
some people say 100 million americans
but i'm getting conservative and saying
50 million americans who live with
chronic pain um
20 million of them yes 20 so that's more
than i think heart disease and diabetes
combined
um and if you add in like 100 million
that's diabetes heart disease and cancer
combined look at the number is
enormous and 20 million of them
live with debilitating chronic pain so
that's the kind of chronic pain
that limits your ability to work to
socialize to conduct functional life
tasks
and so that population
though is only being served by
about 4 000 pain specialists meaning
that there's less than one pain
specialist
for every 10 000 americans who live with
chronic pain
wow so 95
of chronic pain patients don't get
access to specialized care
and then even those who do right those
are pain specialists who are seeing
40 patients a day and are being
um incentivized for
the injections and the procedures
and not necessarily for lengthy visits
that discuss
medication history you know like it's
just it's the way that the system is set
up
plus they're like doing their best to
see as many patients as they can
because there's so few people to offer
this care
um the other challenge
with chronic pain is like as i mentioned
you know it's
it is um subjective
in many ways but it's also best served
by multimodal solutions
because chronic pain when it's so when
pain is last longer than like six months
which is what
would be defined as chronic pain um
solutions that cater to the bio
social emotional like bio
psychosocial environment are the most
effective because the pain
at that point is not just coming from a
physical location
it's coming from pain signals that are
being sent from the brain
there's normally a depression or anxiety
component
there's an isolation component there's
like a movement component
and so unless you're providing a
multi-disciplinary solution
you're gonna have limited outcomes
but i mean what i just explained to you
is not
scalable by most by most healthcare
providers or most health systems like
in a traditional brick and mortar
fashion
you really need this is like an
opportunity that's ripe for
digital intervention because you just
can't offer that service
or those services
math to people who are already having
difficulty
moving right like getting a patient to
go to
one doctor's visit is hard enough when
they're
in so much pain getting them to go to
three different visits
remember them like get value from them
have insurance cover them is just it's
really hard
right and i guess that's where upside
health comes in
so how are you actually helping you know
this this incredible market
that i'm shocked by by the magnitude of
it that we're talking about you know 50
million americans conservative speaking
that have some some sort of chronic pain
how do you help them
well and the other thing to note about
this really large
market size is that we're also talking
about
incredible amount of spending within a
health system so like
right right and average chronic pain
patient goes to the doctor
19 times a year cost the health system
000 so there's more than
600 billion dollars spent every year in
chronic pain costs so
i mean this is not just like a big
market but it's a really expensive one
for health systems payers really
across the board so how do we help how
do we solve this
and it's really about
providing a multi-faceted solution
that providers can easily distribute to
their patients
that allows for not just behavior change
on the
point of the patient but that behavior
change
creates a reduction in clinical burden
um it also creates you know uh
decreased cost for a system and then
incentivizes providers
through it being reimbursable um
the software is mobile software that
uses the best of patient reported data
so everything on mood sleep functional
ability
and then passively collected physiologic
data
to help the patient better understand
what's happening with their pain
uh they help them set goals towards
treatment like what what would be a if
their pain were 50
less for instance what they would do
differently
and then based off of this information
that they provide and that we gather
we connect them to a curated cohort of
other patients
to ensure that nobody hurts alone we
also direct them to integrative wellness
content
so something that responds to their
particular needs at a particular time
so let's say the patient is um
reporting that they're having difficulty
sleeping they're sleeping
under six hours a night
that that sleep is restless we know from
their
physiologic data that we've gathered
that they've been rather sedentary
um and their goal is to they'll be able
to
go grocery shopping so they can have
like some nutritious meals in their
house
the content that we provide maybe in-app
meditations
exercises stretches information about
like sleep hygiene
um interactive content around
preparing a grocery shopping list for
instance and then
support from other patients and our
health coaches to help them reach those
goals
um and then the clinicians on the other
hand get to
view this high level data
uh we'll synth we synthesize the data we
review it with our clinical team and
then we
offer them everything that's required to
build
so that way they don't have to take that
on internally
interesting so i walk me through the the
process i
if i have let's say i have chronic back
pain right
and i am and i need and i'm looking for
that support what is my interaction with
this app on a daily basis as well as how
how does this connect to the triangle
where the patient
the physician and the app how does that
happen
yeah so you i mean you could find the
app for free
um on the app stores but really our
primary
distribution model now is through your
provider so you are going to either your
pain specialist your primary care
provider your neurologist your
orthopedist
and they're saying we're now using this
uh we think that it's medically
beneficial and necessary
for you to be part of this remote
patient monitoring and behavioral health
platform
ouchy here's how you download it um
somebody from their team will also reach
out to help onboard you
um you'll create an account where we
enter some basic information
and then we'll start pulling the data
right away um and then based off of
the data that we're pulling we'll send
you prompts and reminders about changes
in your activity
um to say like okay we've seen these
changes
how do you now respond to these various
patient reported information
and here's some content and community
that we think that will
support you now you're like for
four days of trying this non-opioid
based treatment
away from like earning a prize and then
me
the doctor who has introduced this to
you
can look in real time and see this or i
could see
the monthly reports at the end of each
calendar month
that i receive from the ouchy team
that will give me the insights and how
you've been engaging what
activities you've tried what successes
you've had
how your medication use has changed
what are the correlations between this
and that
um and then you and then the doctor has
the ability to act on that but also to
be able to bill
insurance for that right and it sounds
like there's
a lot of things that this is helpful
with first it allows the distribution of
access right so you can have
uh some pain specialists that are now
looking and supporting multiple
a greater factor of patients because
they're not necessarily looking
and spending an hour with each other
they're looking at higher level data you
can obviously synthesize the data and
come up with some interesting
conclusions
i'm curious about the user experience
side of things because one of the things
that you're mentioning with
with habit formation and goal setting
and which is something that many apps
try to do right in the notorious to-do
list
app that you can write a million to do
they never follow through with them
so talk to me a little bit about goal
setting and habit formation
in the context of chronic pain and how
you're tackling that through user
experience
so one of the problems with the way that
we've gathered and measured pain in the
past is it's like
solely dependent on the pain score and
so it's really hard to see
progress if like every time you're asked
what your pain level is
it's a level h and the reason there's so
many reasons why a patient will give
level eight maybe they really are in
excruciating pain
maybe the doctor won't take them
seriously
if they say six maybe they
um
yeah i mean there's just a lot so pain
score a lot of times doesn't vary
and so to help a patient see progress
you have to ask
questions about things just outside of
pain score
and you have to make them both specific
enough and general enough
that the patient can see progress
throughout so
we tie progress to
small functional tasks but based off of
what the patient
is changing in their pain score or their
mood and their sleep we'll rearrange
them in a different order
so that way the patient can see progress
and the progress will change um based
off of um
based off of various other scores
and also we don't there's some things
that we
ask in terms of smart goals
you know if you're paying more there's
also the way that you ask a question
right
if your pain were 50 less what would you
do differently
we're not asking patients to complete
tasks for the sake of completing tasks
we're giving them tasks that are part of
their regular
life and asking them how close they are
to completing it
and then we reward them for things that
they might not realize at our
accomplishments
but sticking with something for instance
it's almost like the surprise of you've
been
hanging in there that's a reward
cheering on other users
and then through time those things
become habit um
every time our users update they have an
option to either post privately
just for themselves or their provider or
publicly to the ouchy community
what we see is a lot of users start
posting privately
but are still engaging in like the cheer
and support of others and then over time
they transition
into being part of the community in a
more complete way
so we aren't forcing the users to do
anything that they're not doing but bit
by bit
like introducing behavior change
techniques
um i think the other thing that you know
is missed a lot of time with
just like forcing a program onto
somebody
is not meeting them where they're
already at
so with chronic pain patients a lot of
these patients have been
dismissed a lot of these patients have
had to go to a lot of different
providers before
um they find one that
is specialized as i mentioned there's
not a lot of specialized providers so a
lot of patients are still being seen by
their primary care doctor who doesn't
have enough time
and so creating um
a an immediate contact with the patient
of like acknowledgement and recognition
and saying
okay we see that these are the problems
that you're having right now here are
some solutions
right on this platform that can help you
with that and then we'll introduce
something
maybe that you haven't thought of but
until you can address some of like the
immediate need
um it's really hard to gain the patience
trust that like we're really on their
team
we're not just trying to like
for something upon them that the doctor
wants i don't know if that makes sense
and then we have to build that trust on
that
as well then we have to build this trust
on the clinical side as well that like
we're not trying to create more work for
them that we know
um how challenging their jobs are right
like
we have to build not not like a
marketplace but you do
have two different types of clients that
you're trying to support
hundred percent you know it makes
perfect sense that the complexity is
there
the the importance of it is there the
you know the sensitivity is there
and because i think i think one of the
interesting complexities introducing
here the layer of
the user experience of trying to
identify the pain and measure
something that is qualitative and not
quantitative but you're trying to do it
you know in a way that is aligning
incentives because at the end
your incentive is to gauge their their
real pain so that you can help them form
their habits and pass that information
to the clinton to the physician
their incentive is to get better and
there is sort of them
this misalignment in the industry right
now where if you don't if you're if
sometimes you're not you know dramatic
enough
or exuberant enough about it then
perhaps people are not going to take
you seriously enough especially i'm
guessing in an industry where you're
saying that there's 95 percent
uh people that don't have the care that
they need to have
so it sounds like what you're doing here
is hugely hugely important
i i do have to apologize that i i should
have called this
this show 30 minute leaders are not 20
minute leaders but rachel this has been
fascinating and i want to thank you for
being generous with your time
my last question is the most important
one which is the three words that you
would use to describe yourself
tenacious um
passionate and
compassionate almost to a fault
i like that i like that uh and and i'm
sure that they
you know i'm sure that you have to have
those things in order to do what you're
doing there
and and i i also wish i i wish we could
talk more about it about the journey and
the transition from journalism and
production and media to this but this is
all wonderful rachel
thank you for helping improve people's
lives i love
businesses that are taking and taking
people that need help finding a good
business solution that is a win-win
situation
you know i truly believe that in order
to make a real impact there has to be
aligned incentives you know people don't
work for free in order to have the best
people with you it needs to be a viable
business and that's why i
you know it unapologetically and
unapologetically saying
we're not a non-profit we're a
for-profit business but we're helping
improve people's lives and and that's a
win-win situation that is beautiful
and so thank you for doing that and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you so much for having
me and uh you stay well as well
you